Brady Neil and Darren have done another slightly
strange experiments.
[Inaudible].
They decided to cool balloons down balloons containing
hydrogen with liquid nitrogen.
And of course, when you cool the gas,
it contracts and the balloon follows down.
But of course, as the balloon gets smaller, it's weight, doesn't change it,
displaces less air, and it can't float.
And as you warm it up again, it,
it starts expanding displaces more air and eventually raises
up.
And when it started rising up, of course,
they couldn't resist putting a match to it.
But the strange thing to them was when they put a match to this code balloon,
it didn't make as loud a bang it did when they used a
warm balloon.
When you look at the actual footage,
there isn't all that much difference between the flames that you see.
Bye.
At the camera doesn't have a sense of ears as my colleagues,
but the people in the room definitely noticed a difference.
So what was going on? Well,
the obvious explanation is first of all,
that when the balloon is cold, the rubber is not as stretching.
So when you light it, it won't fly away as quickly.
And secondly, that the gas is the lower pressure because it's colder.
So what this means is that the balloon will burst more
slowly and the gas won't expand as fast.
It won't mix with act so quickly with oxygen and therefore you'll get
the same amount of heat, but it will be released more slowly.
So you won't get the big shock wave that makes group.
The big question is how could you test this?
We thought that perhaps you could test it by putting the hydrogen instead of in
the balloon, in the plastic bag,
because the plastic bag will inflate,
but it's not under tension like balloon. So it will burst much more slowly.
So the gas was not really under pressure at all.
After a quick tray with a sandwich bag taken from one of my students,
she had to have her lunch early.
We then tried with a white plastic, which was tied loosely,
but not really sealed. And when you put the match to it,
there was something which we all thought looked a bit like the Hindenburg air
ship crashing,
the bag caught fire. There was a small fireball,
but no explosion in the same way,
Just that the idea of the rubber being stretched and the fact
that it was the gas was lower pressure might explain the absence of
the explosion,
but we hadn't really demonstrated that the oxygen is also needed.
So we started with a second bag this time green
and the green bag was filled with hydrogen,
but the bottom was left completely open so that the air could go in and mix
with the hydrogen. So we had a sort of mixture of hydrogen and oxygen,
much better to burn. And when we let that.
One.
There was a much more convincing poll,
but still the bag caught fire and just burn.
Yeah.
It would appear that this rather strange experiment with a balloon and liquid
nitrogen was a combination of two effects that balloon didn't
burst so quickly.
And the hydrogen didn't mix with the air as well because its pressure was lower.
But what was quite interesting is that rather than the balloon,
where little bits disappeared across the room and you rarely find them,
we ended up with two quite artistic pieces of burnt
plastic and they've quite hard.
It makes quite a bang.
I'm sure you've all been at children's parties where the little children burst
into tears when the balloon burst because of the noise.